to seriously and finally fix our
immigration system for months now that's
what they've done working around the
clock through the holidays over the
weekends has been an extraordinary
effort by Senators Langford Murphy and
Cinema the result of all this hard work
is a bipartisan agreement that
represents the most Fair Humane reforms
in our immigration system in a long time
and the toughest set of reforms to
secure the Border ever now all all
indications are this bill won't even
move forward to the senate floor why a
simple reason Donald Trump because
Donald Trump thinks it's bad for him
politically therefore he doesn't even
though it help the country he's not for
it he'd rather weaponize this issue than
actually solve it so for the last 24
hours he's done nothing I'm told but
reach out to Republicans in the house
and the Senate and threaten them and try
to intimidate them to vote again against
this proposal it looks like they're
caving frankly they owe it to the
American people to show some spine and
do what they know to be right so I want
to tell the American people what's in
this bill and why everyone from the Wall
Street Journal to border patrol to the
Chamber of Commerce United States
Chamber of Commerce support this bill
because it's going to make the country
safer make the Border more secure treat
people more humanely and freely and and
fairly and make legal immigration more
efficient and consistent with the values
of our nation and our International
treaty
obligations it would finally provide the
funding that I have repeatedly
repeatedly requested most recently in
October to actually secure the
border that includes an additional
1,500 border agents and officers to
secure the border to physically secure
it in
addition 100 cut Edge machines to detect
and stop fentol at the Southwest border
we have that capacity an additional 100
additional immigration judges to help
reduce the year-long Asylum backlog you
show up for Asylum and judge is supposed
to talk to you it takes a year to get
that discussion going this bill would
also establish new efficient and fair
process for the government to consider
an asylum claim for those arriving at
the
border today the process can take 5 to
seven years as you all know they show up
at the border get a bracelet told them
come back when called 5 to seven years
not in country that's too long and it's
not rational with the new policies in
this bill and the additional of
4,300 more Asylum officers who spend
hours I might add with each immigrant to
consider their claims whether they
qualify will be able to reduce that
process to 6 months not five 5 to 7
years this bpru and Bill will also
expedite work permits so those who are
here and who qualify Can Begin work more
quickly that's something that our
Governors our Mayors and our business
leaders have been asking me for and
asking them for all across the country
they've been asking for this it'll also
create more opportunities for families
to come together for business to hire
additional workers and for the first
time in 30 years
the first time in 30 years this
bipartisan legislation increases the
number of immigrant visas for people
legally Legally able to come to this
country through por of entry and it
ensures for the first time that
vulnerable unaccompanied young children
have legal representation at the border
this bill would also give me as
president the emergency authority to
temporarily shut down the Border when it
becomes overwhelmed the numbers are
talking over 5,000 people trying to get
in one day the bill if the bill were law
today it would qualify to be shut down
right now while we repair it bottom line
is this bipartisan bill is a win for
America because it makes important fixes
to our broken immigration system and
it's the toughest fairest law that's
ever been proposed relative to the
border now it doesn't address everything
I'd like that I wanted for example we
still need a path for of mentation for
those who are already here and we're not
walking away from True immigration
reform including permanent protections
and a pathway to Citizens for young
dreamers who came here when they were
children and who have been good citizens
and contribute so much to our country
but the reforms in this bill are
essential for making our border more
orderly more Humane and more secure
that's why the border patrol Union which
by the way endorsed Donald Trump in the
2020 election endorses is this bill
these are the people whose job it is to
secure the border every single solitary
day they don't just show up for photo
ops like some members of Congress
they're there to do their job this is
the risk the thing they many of them
risk their lives doing every single day
and they decided they decided the border
patrol decided this gives them the tools
they need to do the job more Personnel
across the board it's also why the US
Chamber of Commerce endorsed this bill
because they know this bill is not just
good for the Border it's also good for
American Business and for the American
economy and it's why the Wall Street
Journal endorsed the bill with the
headline this morning which reads quote
a border security bill worth passing the
Senate has reforms Trump never came
close to getting that's the quote from
the journal this bill would also address
two other important priorities first it
provides urgent funding for Ukraine
I'm wearing my Ukraine tie my Ukraine
pin which I've been wearing because
they're they're in Dire Straits right
now defending themselves against the
Russian
Onslaught brutal Conquest the clock is
ticking every week every month it passes
without new a Ukraine means fewer
artillery shells fewer defense a air
defense systems fewer tools for Ukraine
to defend itself against this Russian
Onslaught just what Putin wants
ukrainians are fighting
bravely you know you many of you look
around the room here have followed me in
this for a long time I pull together a
coalition of over 50 Nations to support
them on the phone talking to these
leaders we unified NATO remember when we
first came to office NATO was in well
they're all together and actually
increased the size of NATO we can't walk
away now that's what Putin's betting on
supporting this bill is standing up to
Putin
opposing this bill is playing into his
hands as I've said before the stakes on
this fight extend well beyond Ukraine if
we don't stop Putin's appetite for power
and control in Ukraine he won't limit
himself to just Ukraine and the cost for
America and our allies and partners will
rise for those republicans in Congress
who think they can oppose funding for
Ukraine and not be held accountable
history is watching
history is watching the fail support
Ukraine at this critical moment will
never be
forgotten the position of the Maga
Republicans can be characterized by the
New York Times
headline first this is the headline it
reads Trump first Putin second America
third that cannot
pertain this bipartisan agreement also
provides Israel with what it needs to
protect its people and defend itself
against samas terrorist and it will
provide the necessary life-saving
humanitarian assistance for the
Palestinian people by opposing this bill
they're denying Aid to the people who
are really suffering and desperately
need
help you know there's more work to get
this done over the finish line and I
want to be clear doing nothing is not an
option Republicans have to decide for
years they said they want to secure the
board border now they have the strongest
border bill this country has ever seen
we're seeing statements about how many
oppose the bill now look I understand
the former president is desperately
trying to stop this bill because it's
not he's not interested in solving the
Border problem he wants a political
issue to run against me I've all but
said that across the board no one really
denies that that I'm aware of the
American people want a solution that
puts an end to the empty political
rhetoric which is failed to do anything
for so long we have to get the resources
to the border to get the job done so
Republicans have to decide who do they
serve Donald Trump or the American
people are they here to solve problems
or just weaponize those problems for
political purposes I know my answer I
serve the American
people I'm here to solve problems just
months ago that Republicans are asking
for this exact Bill to deal with the
border to provide support for Ukraine
and Israel and now and now it's here and
they're saying never mind never
mind folks we've got to move past this
toxic politics it's time to stop playing
games with the world waiting and
watching and by the way the world is
waiting the world is watching they are
waiting and watching what we're going to
do we can't let we can't continue to let
Petty partisan politics get in the way
of our responsibility we're a great
nation it's not acting like a great
nation so I'm calling on Congress to
pass this Bill gets to my desk
immediately but if the bill fails I want
to be absolutely clear about something
the American people are going to know
why it
failed I'll be taking this issue to the
country and the voters are going to know
that it's not just a moment just at the
moment we're going to secure the border
and fund these other programs Trump and
the Maggie Republicans said
no because they're afraid of Donald
Trump afraid of Donald
Trump every day between now and November
the American people are going to know
that the only reason the border is not
secure is Donald Trump and his magg
Republican friends it's time for
republicans in the Congress to show a
little courage to show a little spine to
make it clear to the American people
that you work for them not for anyone
else I know who I work for I work for
the American people I'm almost like this
we have to remember who in God's name we
are we're the United States of America
you've heard me say it many times
there's nothing beyond our capacity if
we do it together we're right on the
verge of doing it together I hope I hope
and pray they find reason to reconsider
blowing this
up and God bless you all may God protect
our troops folks you're going to ask me
questions hang on a second I'm going to
be back on Thursday I don't want to
Prejudice what may be going on in
negotiations now so I'm not going to be
answering any questions of this I'll be
back Thursday to stand here with you and
answer all the questions you want about
this issue thank
you to get de got resolved
sir
this indirectly has a lot to do with the
hostage deal and what's going on in the
Middle East the decision on what we do
relative to Israel decision what we do
in terms of American funding of whether
we're going to engage with the situation
in Ukraine it all goes to the question
of American power it all goes to was
America keep it word does America move
forward there is some movement and I
don't want
I don't want
to well maybe choose my words there's
some movement there's been a
response
from the
uh there's been a
response from the
opposition but um it yes I'm sorry from
Hamas but it seems to be uh
a little over the top we're not sure
where it is there's a continuing
negotiation right now Mr President if
this bill fails would you consider
supporting something separate that just
addresses Israel or
Ukraine I'm not going to concede that
now we need it all the rest of the
world's looking at us and they really
are this Congress does not have immunity
Mr President your reaction to that
ruling
go